you
[Music]
um
[Music]
hello what is up friends welcome
[Music]
a great opening question uh what
happened to sleep
i have slept i napped i'm good i'm gonna
do a
uh i wanted to do a charity stream for a
couple of hours let me tweet out the
thing
real quick before i head to bed
can you guys hear the music i sometimes
screw that mix up
but i feel like it's good but what do i
know some people tell me it's completely
silent
i did not sleep all day no but i have
slept
[Music]
good volume excellent love to hear
let me send a tweet out um
yeah so welcome everyone hi i'm just
tweeting out the links to the donations
and all that stuff um
i basically just like had had a i've had
a crazy week
um obviously cyberpunk coming out is
really exciting you know having
worked on the game um in a obviously
very small capacity but
still a thing um we hit a hundred
thousand followers on twitch
we hit 550 000 subscribers on youtube
and
500 000 uh followers on instagram
in the last like five days which is
crazy and um
i'm just feeling a little love and the
coolest part about that is that
that's all happened while i get to work
this day job that i absolutely adore
and just feel so passionately about so i
thought that i would just do something
good tonight obviously i want to play
more of the game before i go to bed
anyway like i would have done this
regardless
um it's just played a few hours of
cyberpunk because i wanted to obviously
um but i thought that i would do a
a charity stream at the same time
because why not
um but we are downloading the patch so
we'll be just talking for a little bit
first
um let me
[Music]
do this as well
[Music]
done
but yeah mostly just thank you like it's
also all the game award stuff people
sharing they voted for me has been so
lovely um
i really hope i don't win genuinely
um hoping that does not happen and i
will dread it if it does
but um the positivity is also just
really nice
so i don't know i'm just feeling really
good i
feel very lucky and and i'm in a
tremendously
privileged position so um raza asked how
do you think the jobs you've had will
help you at sony santa monica
you know mostly being a professional
writer for nine years
is probably the most part
do i have a speech prepared in case i
win i had to submit an acceptance speech
uh so that has already been submitted
and
basically what i did is um i was on the
phone
and i had the person i was on the phone
to tell me that i had won
so that i at least like felt like i had
but i don't think i will
uh obviously they had everyone sit in an
acceptance speech so
uh yeah rando it's an issue where twitch
just basically like
butches um
sorry i mean youtube just butches
compression
rocky fan i doubt you missed my
character unless you finish the whole
game
i don't think you'll miss me you will be
pinged i guess it's a side quest that
you could not do but it's not one that
you stumble across you will be alerted
to my side quest and it's one that i
think most people are going to want to
do because
it'll sound very cool to you when you
come across it
uh will i learn prior to the vga if i
won no i will be finding
out live and i am streaming it um with
my friend ethan
a six foot four turkish man is now
scared of me
who's that i don't know who you're
talking about
how do you find me great question marsha
master ishana i don't actually know
also thank you to the person who already
donated 20 yeah the uh this is feeding
america
um basically helping people not go
hungry
is the main thing uh there is if you're
on twitch do the donate command and it
will give you a link if you're on
youtube it's in the description
um we'd love to raise some money for
charity tonight
[Music]
do i sleep miss not much lately not much
lately
i've actually had a lot of trouble uh
sleeping
recently and i was trying to weigh up
whether it's like
just my mind racing about the amount of
stuff that's been happening this week
or me just thinking about how much i
like my job
it's like i don't know which of those
things it is um
which is a weird problem for me as the
sleepiest person in the world
clinically um
let me do an instagram
[Music]
i don't know how other streamers do this
do they like if they do their tweet out
links when they say we're live are they
actually live at that point or are they
lying
i genuinely don't know
swipe up
there's the weirdest thing i'm having
about gog i don't know if anyone's um
familiar with this my internet speed is
quite fast
my gog download speed uh
is so slow
um i really don't know why
yeah can we do all of it
i think everything is up yeah
cool cool cool cool cool
it's actually kind of warm in here today
some streamers were having the same
issue it's really like
i currently have 45 megabits a second
megabytes rather a second but my
download speed is more like
800.
uh razer 49 i'm just seeing another one
of your comments some of the chances of
that
um i don't have a h1 visa or want a h1
visa i'm on an 01 visa which gives me
the amount of flexibility that i have i
can change jobs i can work for however
it's effectively a talent visa um it
also means i can go in and out of the
country pretty readily so
very happy with the visa that i am on
for sure
um all i'm gonna say is we've been live
for eight minutes
i was going to complain that we hadn't
uh hit more than one donation but then
someone else did just donate
i think the 70 dollars there let me
yeah thank you to jacob who's now the
tough donor with fifty dollars and the
other one was funky
fell felines that's somebody's xbox live
name for sure he said thanks for the
content and happy to support the cause
well thank you
you don't know about feeding america
their mission is to feed america oh
uh through food banks basically is what
they do they just
you know help people eat
you'd love to see it
is nightbot still posting the geforce
link
i mean it's not the end of the world but
uh what do i think about the xbox one
and ps4 gameplay i've not seen any of it
i've also not read any reviews
i don't have to do anything like that
anymore it's great
thank you spoonamus i really appreciate
that uh why did i switch the elgato mic
i have a video that will probably go up
on i think i have it scheduled for the
19th
um i haven't edited it yet that is i
upgraded a bunch of stuff about my
um pc gaming setup
and i wanted to get a new microphone
because my microphone was having trouble
with streams sometimes there would be
like a hum in the background or there
was a lot of noise
has a lot of editing required it also
has pretty bad peaking
so i got a new microphone um i bought it
over
black friday
good stuff it is the same uh mike troy
uses jeff and that's why i got it
actually is because
i edit play watch listen not all the
time um we do have another editor on it
sometimes
uh but troy's mic requires the least
editing
so that's why i was like i would love to
get on that um because this mic so good
and and means that i don't have to work
very hard
did the youtube stream screw up am i
reading this correctly
it's definitely there that's strange we
have so few viewers on
on youtube compared to normal like
shockingly few that it's it's like like
maybe like
three quarters um maybe a glitch or
something i don't know or it's the time
no i've had they've had way more
whatever because
point is trying to raise money for
charity thank you people who just
donated
we got 20 from anonymous twenty dollars
from
dustin mims who said feeding america one
dollar at a time indeed
and then link shadow what is it link
shadow come on
come on it won't show link shadow blue i
hear it from down under keep up the good
work oh thank you
zombae said happy to see you loving your
job uh happy to see you in general
zombie just in general but thank you
austinite for the 150 dollars he said if
it helps uh it sure does
we feeding people out here it helpful
jairon i don't think it really works
that way um
because my audience doesn't come from
those same places i don't think so
people are just playing cyberpunk that's
true
people could just be playing cyberpunk
have you ran the game on my current pc
setup i sure have
i did it yesterday if you want to see
the stream uh it runs great
thanks to my new 3080 mostly
um it could look like i'm running at 30
frames a second
on the stream but i'm not
what are we at we're at 60 frames a
second for sure
on the output but sometimes youtube
compresses things it makes them ugly
appreciate that callum they said the
youtube notification hasn't gone live
sorry for caps making sure you see this
to fix it i cannot fix it
um i
don't have any way to fix that just
youtube being youtube
um digital nomad i don't know what you
mean by that question
how long have you ever streamed i'm not
sure what you mean by that either joe
the longest stream i ever did was like
24 hours i think
hey thank you rumblefish i do love those
grumps i'm a huge fan of aaron
like obviously i'm friends with a lot of
people who make youtube content
um aaron's just so normal and i love
that about him
he's just a he's just a [ __ ] dude you
know who doesn't even really know how to
use his computer he's just
he's just a dude he's great he's so
chill
oh the charity foundation that i want to
make is that we talking about from the q
a
um i'm not going to talk about it
especially because i'm currently
processing business applications with
the us government
i'm going to do that whoa when did we
hit 460
when did that happen what
[Music]
thank you spencer who said thanks for
your podcast they're awesome
i appreciate that we're actually we
usually record on a tuesday
this week for players listen we're
recording on friday um in part because
it worked better for people's schedules
but also because
even though none of us really care
enough to cater the content around it um
not care is the right word it's like it
just doesn't you know
invoke the same level of discussion as
other things do we
figured it would make sense to record
after the game awards so
doing that friday um so i don't know
what the topic is yet
drinking coffee always drinking coffee
i'm not saying aaron is better than dan
i just don't know dan as well obviously
dan's like one of the most pleasant men
in existence both very normal well i
guess dan is like the lead singer of a
pretty wild band i don't know how normal
he is for that he's basically a rockstar
uh lex you cannot donate through super
chat but i've said this before
i will always take the donations from
super chat if you want to to apply later
but it takes like 30 days i can't do it
immediately so it won't go up into the
counter whatever
560. why didn't it happen
uh another anonymous one one from
christopher who said food insecurities
and poverty is a big part of my career
thank you for organizing this fundraiser
well that's an awesome career to have
thank you for
being on that for a living evil donated
fifty dollars
and richie donated twenty dollars who
said happy to help lana congrats on the
job mate and being in the game plus
congrats on your hairstyle being in the
cyberpunk game lol i really hope that's
not
uh richie who has been a stalker
that would suck but thank you for
donating regardless
we'll take it it was definitely written
like him if it's a completely different
ritchie than uh
props to the other richie
but that dude sucks um yes the link is
in the description on youtube
and uh the command prompt on
twitch if you guys want to find it
why do you keep yelling at me to wake up
is this a dream this could legitimately
be a dream i don't know
oh he's so much of a creep that i know
his name yeah and his home address
and i've reported him to the police oh
yeah gets out of hand
who is the hardest to say goodbye to
from the fun house crew
um i don't feel like i ever said goodbye
we recorded a video today
so it's not a problem
um totally not a not an issue i i am
seeing john and jacob soon and want to
say those two
aren't high risk um they don't have
compromised immune systems
but because we wanted to see each other
over christmas
um with a very small group it's
literally us basically
um we're going away and they've like
agreed to really strictly isolate
and to um like everyone's getting tested
but basically i i had to be like hey
guys are we cool to
completely strictly isolate and like not
even accept like a doordash order in
person for the next
few weeks and they were like yeah
absolutely
um you know obviously we'll still stay
really distanced when we're together and
stay out of each other's ways and all
that stuff but i
it just means a lot to me i really love
those dudes so
yeah i never felt like i had to say
goodbye to funhouse i i kept
i feel like i said that in videos it's
like i didn't feel like i said goodbye
to them you know it's just um
i don't feel like i left the family at
all i'm sure i'll still make content
with them all the time so
uh stefan asked livestream commentary on
game awards
yes i'll be doing it tomorrow obviously
same as everyone else
[Laughter]
uh fleet admiral i'm starting from a
previous save i will be starting from
the last save that i did
uh or the last stream that i did which
was
this morning at [ __ ] what time did i do
it
um we're at 85 by the way um
i don't know i think i stopped streaming
at like six so
when's your first day at santa monica i
started a month ago
how do i get good mic audio a great
question good microphone
um don't have an echo environment uh
having any like
panels on walls can really help um
anything to
prevent bouncing is really one of the
biggest problems of audio
um that's that's mostly it
it's really your environment is super
important so
that's the big one do i ever sleep are
you a vampire
i sleep so much because cfs you know
lately i've actually been great
i've been doing really well this year
because i can manage things really well
but uh you know i will sleep for like 15
16 hours on a weekend
generally to make up for stuff
uh street side yes i'm on twitch and on
youtube
made weird crackling noises this mail i
haven't seen any of that that's really
strange
um scooterman gaming one of my mods said
yo take my money and make the world a
better place
uh i'm not technically taking your money
that would suck for taxes
um but i will make the world a better
place thank you very much
and then courtnberry donated 20 thank
you for that
uh what song is this this is called safe
on your own
by dream hour
[Music]
well with papa bruce and so law i'm sure
we will like continue to do drunk
streams until the end of time
um but covert really spiked recently so
not anytime soon
uh yes alex 100 donations go to said
charity
indeed like video games ready
hello let me
boot it up and then jump it over to you
[Music]
guys
thank you for the 20 lex i appreciate
[Music]
that
there you are video game you love to see
[Music]
it
[Music]
did you buy on gog i was given a code
because my name is in the credits
morning thank you let's swap you over
to the dust video game and then make
myself
way smaller i don't need to be that big
there we go is that too small
maybe like there
i don't know uh how is game audio you
guys
is that okay sounds good
yes no yes
hey
turn it up a bit are you sure
it's so loud in my headphones that i
really don't know
i feel like we're okay i feel like we're
okay
uh thank you to kyle for the twenty
dollars you said good luck with the
stream i'm skipping for spoilers and
sleep i'm rooting for you at the awards
you don't have to that's very kind uh i
don't know if he's still here but thank
you kyle
i really like this menu song actually i
want to see if this is on
spotify because it is sick
[Music]
i can't see anything yet i mean i'm sure
it all will be
but at this point i can't see [ __ ]
the song's dope god it's so cool
um also i guess for anyone who's
watching who happens to be a content
creator
if you didn't see a cd project tweeted
i started saying project because that's
how they say it but then i feel like
such a wanker but um they tweeted saying
the brain dances still currently have
uh copyrighted songs
um like two of them that they're waiting
to patch out so
you would need to turn all music off of
the brain dances so that you don't get
stuck by that uh thank you jl mcmichael
for the 20 villains we are raising money
for feeding america um
to raise money for food banks basically
is the idea
okay
[Music]
malibu lizard you should tell me to [ __ ]
off and go to sleep at like 12. i
i napped late today
so um
i'm okay i think feels great to have you
back
probably not overall i got to be up
really early tomorrow aircraft carrier
docked in night city
we'll see the whale
apparently it's hurting your eyes that's
not good
afraid how long am i going to be playing
probably a couple hours i'm up i'm upset
that nightbot just told zombie to stop
spamming
let me make her a mod look how dare you
do that to her
who do you [ __ ] think you are you are
you one of these
jerks trying to silence her you too
nightbot get out of here
that's absurd oh hang on let me make her
a mod
where is she i mean of course i think i
can just go slash
mod uh and then
huh does that do it hey
[Music]
hey we did it okay cool
thank you christopher thank you draco
for the three dollars and then thank you
el
zottle for the 25 um yeah if you're on
again this is the first time i've ever
managed to do it so very big moment for
me if you're on
hey buddy um
twitch you do the exclamation mark and
then the donate and you can donate hey
bud
what are you about yeah
um go talk to jackie i guess
uh if you're on youtube the link is in
the description
hey bud so
what's up you know just chilling
i mentioned something about a surprise
is the audio okay i'm remembering writer
good
just had brain fart probably both uh
random guy i spawned in the last place
that i was
it's not safe sir
i have actually already played all of
this
and i will note that the first time i
played it the box he was holding was
invisible
totally the top fixer in night [ __ ]
city
fat ass black jesus of the afterlife
300 pounds of partly gold-plated
cool uh i really like dex edition
i think he's cool as hell what's the
latest spec on him
know you got in photos phil he's been
off the couch i wonder who had
voice actresses i actually don't know i
think she sounds super cool
guessing he shoved pizzas in his mouth
while jerking off the hardcore virtues
the important thing is he's back
so what's the gig we meant to come out
in one piece i think this game is so
crazy behavior wouldn't tell you
everything
really just constantly blows me away no
pressure but
don't get me wrong don't got nothing
against the padre
that's the nudes a great question
has he actually eaten any of them yet
he eats but there's no noodles in the
chopsticks
do it again jackie i dare you what are
you eating buddy
gonna be long nothing ah
um don't get me started on fixers
they catch a client find the cheapest
gonk to do the job then drop their
quarterback
somebody just donated 250 dollars and we
just hit 1000.
holy heck thank you so much uh dj mafia
let me let me check the message
i love that it translates what he says
that's also very cool
thanks
thanks jack much appreciated love
credits
love credits um
uh richie donated another ten dollars
definitely is
the dude who is an abusive piece of crap
that's a huge problem please leave uh i
will contact hillary and ban you from
the platform
go away um jaymathia said i just wanted
to be the first for a while i think
you'll be the first for a while with
that 250 bud
i think you're okay there that's amazing
um all right one thing that i know this
no one's gonna care about this
um but is extremely cool is uh
top-notch when you tab out of this game
the audio stays and it continues to play
um i hate it when audio disappears when
i tap out of a game when i'm streaming
it's it's very annoying let's feel this
factory new ride
oh right it's vehicle time
let's go
so this is all the like it's still like
act one stuff you guys would have all
seen
a ton of times um we still mad early i
don't even feel like this is spoilers
have i met myself yet i have not
i'm pretty far away i think really gets
me you know
i have no idea whether and i kind of
don't want to ask them i'm happy that it
can be a surprise for me too
um that i will find out at pretty much
the same time everyone else does where i
am i suspect someone on the internet
will find me before i do because you
know
i work a full-time job um
can't necessarily get through video
games as fast when playing video games
is no longer my job
because making them is my job
this is where i saw ko the first time
i assume that's how you say his name i
think this is him
carnage only a content creator
do you truly believe that those who have
sold you your mechanical
eyes have resisted the temptation to
peek through them yeah
cameras are all around us oh i don't
know how to say it i'm sorry
um your worries your life for them it is
all mirrors but this is him
there you go uh oh i didn't know i could
talk to him
um okay let's just say you're right so
what
should i just gouge out my optics no
thanks but no thanks
he looks like he's wearing a trash bag
are beyond salvation
but not the children of the future life
untainted by surgery of the sacrilege
thank you we can yet save them may the
mothers shield their bodies this would
have been fun to do
this would have been fun to voice
who are those who follow our every step
is this where you live bro
why the titans of entertainment alpha
centauri
pretty sick in their wretchedness they
placate their weary i didn't know you
could interact with him
so there you go cool that you can do
that on full display
that's funny havoc
i think this game's amazing people i'm
again obviously biased i'm like so
hesitant to say it but i feel like when
i'm walking around environments like
this
like look at it
my gosh okay
this is his lady in it i think so dr
vector will see you now
i'll sit tight over here me and misty
got a little catching up to do pretty
sure that's his lady
okay is there anything to do around here
i never explored it
this loot it's a [ __ ] rpg wow i
didn't
mean to do that that was an accident
a cat oh you can pet the cat
oh my gosh i hope that there's a dog
that i can pat
somewhere i like your hair i would rock
all of that style
why's everyone got it out for me
i thought it was gonna let me pat the
suicidal kid
bro what are you can we can i have that
gun please
sir man
what i won't buy anything from you
if you're his mother you wow okay
sorry i forgot that people stare at you
when you look at them and it actually
does make it kind of an uncomfortable
experience
um because it's like being acknowledged
when i'm just trying to like look at
your character model can you not look me
in the eyes man
you don't need any of that through a
comment
though a common practice cyberware
installation is still a dangerous and
invasive procedure which can
only be performed by qualified
specialists cool
hit me up right good to see you
too what do i owe the
pleasure today i would like cyber
weapons had to jack into a client's
narrow socket
i think i might have gotten spiked
experience i don't know how she decided
that she'd been spiked
i do not remember positivity the bright
lights oh kitten caboodle
how long have i been playing i would say
this is two hours into the game
mcsantago how are things
i had a dexterity gave me a job
name's dexter desean known quantity
from the afterlife no denying your movie
afterlife i think are the like cool
group of fixers that are well known but
they're not like a gang
keep your guard up i remember correctly
i've heard some things about
dex he's not as chill as he makes
himself out to be
hmm need some nutrition i don't know
what happens with him you know i don't i
don't know the outcome
of any of that stuff
really now finally
thick shit's getting real got a job from
dexter sean
hit in the major leagues any tech that
can perform
the dexter desean well
that is something but let me guess
hasn't paid you yet he has not
wait somebody gave me money yeah let's
do that
crying vic i'll bring you the eddies
later with interest
you know i will hmm
last time you're here this game's
stunning
i tell you stunning beautiful
look at it that's ridiculous sit down
relax the one thing and i let me just
see how it looks i
because my goddamn light for streaming
is in my eye
it sucks so bad i'm just gonna turn this
off
see how terrible it looks it's fine
you guys can deal with that because now
i can see the game better
it looks even prettier for me um we can
deal with the shadow on my face
it's never hurt anybody i'm trying to
play video games man i'm not out here
trying to be a model
okay
a night stream indeed jeff thank you
grocery optics
best i've got shout out
it didn't change anything i mean it
definitely did the lighting for sure is
different
but it's fine
okay yeah yeah i'm sorry jackman
you peruse and choose while i scan see
what's going on i think i have to choose
something here
um let me read out some more donations
first
for anyone who's just joining us we are
doing this stream for charity
and i have to thank
that's amazing austinite donated 251 and
said oh no you can't dj
mafia03 it's for a good cause because
they dethroned
that's funny um firekeeper tc just
donated 100
and then edgar torres donated five
dollars we're raising money for feeding
america
uh which is basically raising money for
food banks to feed people who need
to eat which is pretty good cause i
think
um
you jump back over to video game yeah
the links are everywhere just in all of
the obvious places
you know you know what i'm saying
i think that i'd have to do both
i believe it is required i would like to
see like can i look at anything else
what does this do increases the breach
time
adrenaline booster
um immune system nothing to install it
says
that's interesting can i get an immune
system cyber
enhancement karen zikov
allows you to aim and shoot while
dodging slows time by 50 for 1.5 seconds
oh my god i want that wow that's cool as
hell
and this grants immunity to shock
increases alma by 20.
sorry i just never looked through any of
this when i played it in preview
heavy loads nice nice nice nice nice
oh it's the same thing i would just have
two slots for it got it
okay ballistic co-processor
increases the chance to ricochet shots
with power weapons
i can't afford it another right oh no i
can
and that's gonna be it doc mark one like
i said
decent enough let's go displace data on
your corner
cherry on the tops of built-in external
lens disrupter
layman's terms any surveillance cam will
capture your faces lucifer i recognize
that a lot of people
um have had issues with the performance
i did have
really bad crashes and then i had to do
a windows update and then i fixed all
that pretty much
had one crash since talks to corrosion
otherwise
i feel like the game's running very well
for me i'm sure i'll eat my words and
it'll break i don't doubt that people
have had those experiences
frankly i think that i expect there to
be a lot of bugs just based on the way
the development went
um of yours but i feel like i expected
it to be a lot worse than it is just
based on the way people are talking
about it thanks but i also keep trying i
i don't feel right
even talking about this game in this way
because
you know they paid me um i just forget
sometimes that i
i'm not supposed to give my genuine
opinions anymore
billy duck makes you sound like a
dentist
always going on don't be mean now
remember i'm old i got a shaky ganic
hand
you don't look that old dude what are
you like 35
lights out for a minute all right
yeah he's not that old
should we all close our eyes is it like
asmo
oh i can share my opinion anthony it's
just people get very mad about it
because of bias and that making you want
and i guess i'm uncomfortable doing it
because everything i have to say about
this game is very positive it just
doesn't feel comforting first
but whatever i'm very impressed by the
game
i can't wait to play this in ultra wide
and not stream it
probably this weekend that's it
seen more dramatic improvements before
patience kid give it a minute
scanning people with your optical
cyberware can provide you with a lot of
useful information such as how strong an
enemy might be who is in that crew
or what type of weapon they use
time for the scanner
says he's 60 percent resistant to fire
first that's pretty sick with anything
really
scanner should eventually sync with your
thought processes
and read your intentions what did that
what was that
i don't know cool thanks i also inject
an ncpd file search
run antennae there dude wells you know
exactly what thing there did well
nice
so i know these you can get
um like special quests from that will
give you special weapons and stuff
basically
from what i think be nice to be 60
resistant to fire you know fun fact
um no
living organism has ever been fire
resistant
i don't know why i find that fact so fun
but i do
there you have it there are animals or
creatures rather that can live in
extremely high temperatures but nothing
is fire resistant
it's a real prick that fire it ought to
work like a jar
now draw your weapon you should see your
ammo count in a brand new site
i think it's small how they integrate it
the ones under the ocean are not fire
resistant dead wing they can be heat
resistant
will the stream be upgraded later
um upload it i'll just leave it up
probably
i'm like while we were putting in your
implant it's a lot of cyberpunk content
in a small amount of time often circuits
zap the critter you're certified bug
free
thanks victor not bad i don't know what
to say
say you'll take this and remember the
dosage two whiffs now
and another two in an hour okay
you're the best vic i owe you loves an
inhaler
i wonder what they did about the drug
use in australia show them what you mean
i was like positive this game wouldn't
come out in australia
don't forget where you came from i would
never
jackie sent me a message i'm really just
stealing all this rip-a-duck stuff huh
he gives me the stuff that i i i need
and then
i just take all this [ __ ]
okay guide up you who's winning
hernandez you know in the old days that
crippled malone would have been flat on
the boards
now every last fighter's got extra skull
line
absorbs 75 of every blow you make this
fall boring
miss it don't you
how's biz going can't complain
corporals learned to keep their distance
and zak is back hiring lone mercs
they all got to have the newest shiniest
implants
i think you got misty here to help
handles your gripe and whoa
yeah retin outer shop's the best
decision i ever made
know what seems like you're the only
person in night city who's happy with
this law
ray tracing baby you drop all your
illusions
life just gets easier from there
i like him wait have i asked him this
question i have haven't
i uh can't complain corporal's learned
to get it doesn't want me to talk to him
zach is back higher is it not mercs i
think you got misty here to
skipping just skipping seems like you're
the only per
you get to a certain yeah um is it
because it wants me to pay him off i
don't want to pay him off though
i wanted to use that money in the next
quest
i guess maybe no i can't okay i'm not
talking to you victor i'm leaving
uh maybe i'm the other way
wait what's this what's this blue marker
why is this here
yes i will take an old plastic gas mask
thank you did i miss something
why are you wanting me to talk to him so
bad anything in here anything in here
frag grenade
was that i do not know
um
can i
do journal messages that i'm gonna need
to read the message from jackie right
uh i'd love to
how to get to you it really just wants
me to talk to victor though
um can i can i just leave can i just
because wasn't this the door
now i'm confu it opens it opens cool
never mind it just opens that's sure
that's chill
all right and then i go talk to jackie
uh this way
there we go hey girl hey
she cute um
he's gonna be out here you can recognize
i'm not sure if this is a glitch
isn't it late for me it is pretty late
yeah
it is 10 58.
um oh it's my grandma's birthday i need
to call her
in a bit um let me yeah i'll uh i'll
reload the save just give me a second
let me read some donations here at
guitarist i think i might have read
another one five dollars jeff mccray
thank you he said canadian donating a
little to help an australian help feed
americans for five dollars
and then an anonymous two dollars thank
you i appreciate it
okay we got a reload
coming here
i think i think
i'm gonna call my grandma on the stream
she'd have
no concept of what streaming is no idea
okay there we go
it fixed itself you idiot
guard up you idiot
okay sorry cat not today
you're hot chocolate very good a little
out of focus i wonder where he was then
if when i came out he wasn't here
but you'd have to watch out for negative
energy fields and avoid mean reds
yo listen up yeah what up talk to dex
while you were in with the doc
he's waiting in his ride for you
ain't gonna hop to where he's parked
next to gramsci burgers
okay do my best to tuck us up
cuckoo
oh hey
now that's probably not news to you but
this issue matters to me
for a few reasons there are people who
say cyberpsychosis can be treated
right um and i know exactly how that
sounds
but i believe even that's interesting
it's still better than a bullet to the
brain
if i get a tip about a possible attack
i'll give you a call
maybe you can investigate before max
attack hits the scene
but remember you're not there to execute
anybody
try to incapacitate the attacker and
i'll send someone to pick them up
i hope that's all clear the cyber
psychos are basically like mini bosses
they're like monster hunter um
i think it's more like monster hunters
how i've described it before i don't
know if i already said that or not but
yeah you can get cool loot and stuff
from them so
uh bernie not i read both chats
they show up on the same screen um
horace edgemary hey ellen i have a
question that why gamespot gives 7 out
of 10 i mean seriously she give this
rating because she over expecting the
game at least they give 8 out of 10
because of bugs but seriously 7.
um ultimately people have different
opinions on things
thus people give things different scores
and it should not mean anything to you
at all that one person that you don't
know gives something a different score
to what you personally feel like the
game should be
it doesn't mean they're wrong it doesn't
mean their opinion is invalid it doesn't
mean your opinion is invalid
people just have different opinions and
i also think review landscapes are a lot
more interesting
with a variety of opinions um if every
single review reads exactly the same
there's not a lot of value for players
who often read things with different
opinions in mind
i think your best bet is to find a
reviewer that you agree with and read
their stuff
um not have an expectation for what a
game deserves
across the board it's just silly so uh
basically the answer is
that's just like your opinion man
yo miss v a pleasure dexter deshawn in
the flesh
ample indeed
mind if i ask you something right off
the bank
yeah would you rather live in pieces
miss nobody die
ripe old and smelling slightly of urine
or go down for all times in a blaze of
glory smelling near like posts live in
peace
why caught into the question the way
that i want to answer the question
uh i strongly disagree with that
my actual answer to this question is how
much good can i do
um there's some sort of test there's
some sort of test hello
he said hello after i asked him because
i waited too long
oh funny riddles feels so rage too i do
not agree at
all i was playing rage 2 last week for
no reason listen close
scanning a serious job now playing guard
apparently it's really bad on
not allowed consoles um that seems to be
the
the ammo but i've not played it on them
so
why maybe why the show got a question of
my own though
why all this dex why not oh we got
someone donations
in here let me wait till there's another
organic
pause shall we
so here we are besides all that
just got a special little pre-mission
just for you
but we'll get to that
i'm gonna push this over here
um yes sorry mate let me hear it
just uh you don't understand i'm just
changing my setup it's very cyberpunk
prototype
a biochip to be precise jobs to grab it
simple hmm
guessing it belongs to a corp mm-hmm
arisaka surely that's no problem
corpse don't deserve special treatment
in agreement
you ain't playing around you got a
feeling this could be a start of a
beautiful friendship
built on heaps of enemies you work this
out got a plan two things
first a conundrum with the maelstrom
boys needs active resolving that
second to rendezvous simple client who
brought us the jobs anxious
she wants to parlay with one of the team
what's your thing that's going to be
american me woman's name's evelyn parker
oh evelyn that's right she's the one in
the box i was looking for any kind of
issues
so it's myriad so it's judy they're all
hot some brothers from pacifica got back
to me
i'm very excited to just get to the
point of the game that i haven't played
yet
anyway that'll be super fun
i feel like i've lived this experience
so so uh in depth in my own mind that
yours truly will be remote things
changing is very very exciting
and jagger's only good at some things i
know you know what i mean
pretty much you what's the issue needs
resolving with maelstrom
got a beef slot in the shard
i wouldn't be accepting these things
from strangers as much as she does
at all um rick sanchez i have no idea
i recognize that there are people saying
that there are major problems with this
game on console but i cannot speak to
those as i have not played it
and i do not know about any patches i
don't know about any of that
great military how was work today thank
you for asking robert dennis don't get
that bad
i don't get no soccer it's good these
shoes have a great day
happily ever after but don't get excited
very tired obviously
but i knew this week would be hard no
matter what i slide out purchase the
damn thing from maelstrom
problem is i did so from a gentleman by
the name of a brick kind of name is
brick
i say when because brick was the leader
three days after we'd see the idea
his friend and gang mate won simon
randle aka royce
playing he dropped his ass
now and i got no way of knowing if he
aims to honor his predecessor's word
to add to the ships from one meredith
style of militech has developed an
interest in said convoy
royce guy what's he like a straight
psychopath chrome loving kind
big club in this town
i'll give you that except few of its
other members no matter the stakes would
put a friend and associate through an
industrial microwave
dryer apparently first thing to burst
out the eyeballs
get a nice clear pop then the rest goes
i have heard that about eyeballs also i
feel like i'm talking a lot less in the
stream than i normally do but it's
because i'm
letting them talk no it's a professional
streamer
okay i don't know what's going on i'm
doing my best
internal affairs been skidding around
town asking after the convoy as
if her life depended on finding it the
one lead she's got
zip tied in her trunk stick up her eyes
ain't growing any shorter
so she must be getting she is a complete
joke i think how you could use that
of course to do so you'll need to
theoretically kill this man in the
driver like you could just kill all
these major characters
i don't think you could kill dexter
desean but i genuinely don't know
anything um time i got to work i don't
think
that's just music to my ears i think the
way they do it is he's not in an
environment where the player is able to
pull out a gun
is he wearing a boob tube one more thing
he might be quiet
or blaze of glory quiet life please
later now
bye yeah my guess is the way that they
do that is that have they have the
important
uh well you couldn't kill jackie i don't
know but i also don't want to try i
guess i could load a safe
do i plan on doing anything with any of
my former funhouse bros i said this
before but i recorded a fun house video
today
and yeah we will continue to stream and
make content and hang out and all that
stuff so
all good
how long am i gonna stream probably
another hour
um until i get tired gotta go to sleep
and i wanted to read some more donations
from scrabby a bunch of little bits make
a lot so here's to helping that is true
thank you for the five dollars drafts at
helping to help five dollars
jacob r said in the stumps to fire every
year one of the highlights has been
finding your channel so happy to see all
of your success and looking forward to
many more milestones in the future thank
you jacob that's very nice
it's 54. was he trying to equalize he
was
tidy work i appreciate that too um
yeah if you guys want to donate we are
feeding hungry americans
the uh link should be in all of the
descriptions
um performing certain actions will
reward you with street cred build your
street cred
yeah i know certain clothing items are
only available
uh if you have a certain amount of
street cred and all that stuff
guy certainly knows how to protect his
biz wants to put us on a few small kings
prep work this looks cool before lining
us up a big job i'm just gonna go to it
because it looks cool
combat bought military prototype
maelstrom clapped it then decks paid to
take it off their hands
just before the gang goons had to switch
up a manager
all right brian heard about that royce
versus prick
hostile i wonder if like you play this
enough you get to a point where you're
just familiar with the city
because it really does feel like a real
city
don't know how much help she stands to
be
i just kind of wanted to see if i could
go explore this area oh uh
royce yeah you don't sound thrilled
royce what do you know about him he's
[ __ ] wack something special
what are you all doing is this fashion
or are you working
unclear then there's the other thing
gotta meet the client who put the job on
the table
evelyn parker oh hey you guys just
hanging out having a good time
i don't know what i've just walked into
for the record but here i [ __ ] must
know
um i wanted to go to the client first
i think i ought to see her first see
what she's this is brain dances
in that case i'll hit the all foods put
my nose to the ground
sniff around
how's this work any punk off the street
can waltz in here grab some shady
running soft
no not just any punk
over the counter we fix cyber decks
but if you come recommended and you know
what you are looking for
i'm sure you will find it
did she debug sent me said you'd have
something for me i was kind of rocked up
here
right she had me hold the demon for you
it should work on any third gen deck i
don't know what that means
the eddies have already changed hands
between me and my eyes team nostrum
partners and business around some ten
dollars
so when you're there to take it off
their hands don't let them try to shake
you down
oh
yeah that's right okay
um got a militech paralyme i think it'll
do solid gear
for a beginner
okay glad you grabbed the demon don't
know what it is don't know what you're
getting
now i have an access point if you'd like
that is you might extract some shim soft
or
subroutines seems worth a try either way
okay
that quick hex this is the one that she
wants to give me
[Music]
cool
i think this might be the first time
that i've streamed an rpg you know and
maybe that's what feels weird about
streaming it
is because there's so much dialogue and
i want to spend so much time in menus
i'm definitely not going to stream the
whole game um happy to to stream to
raise money for charity obviously by the
way before you money for free america
linkedin is in the description or if you
do the donate command on twitch you'll
you'll get it um but it like occurs to
me that it feels weird to do this
for some reason you know
i don't never thought about it before
same feeling you had with valhalla yeah
uh out of curiosity what was the
reasoning from sony that you weren't
allowed to say
who your job was with for a couple of
weeks doesn't seem like it would have
negative effects on the studio but i'm
not familiar with the industry
everything works that way um rooster
teeth said the same thing
they basically just don't want you to
say you're walking somewhere until
you are every company does that
uh that has any kind of like public
presence
pretty much literally all of them
rooster teeth was like really specific
about it
i feel like it makes sense um i wonder
if there's any
witch easter eggs there are can confirm
there are
previous job i had even did it for
internal positions yeah loads of them do
i feel like it's um
it's pretty normal um anyway okay
well i don't want to spend any money
okay we'll figure that out eventually um
because
i want to keep all my money for the
maelstrom mission
in case i need it
basically oh am i going to see my
reflection
i can't how does that work let me make
sure we do have ray tracing on and it
didn't
turn itself off we on we on ultra
pretty much everything is on high
you'd love to see it except obviously
videos
it's 1080 i believe yeah
um okay
i will play in 4k super ultra wide
aspect ratio
so when i can last honest
her name's anna hamill and whatever
she's investigating
it's made her a lot of enemies she'd do
best to cut it out if you catch my drift
okay look i know how it sounds but
somebody would have taken this gig
anyway right
i don't know maybe there's an angle you
can play here
either i'll do the side quest
that was an accident i did not mean to
do that
i didn't mean to do that i guess i could
fight him
i was trying to scan oh gosh
my bad
it's all right you know sometimes you
just accidentally pull a grenade out it
doesn't do as much damage as i hoped it
would
whoa wait did they just throw a grenade
they threw something hey hey hey stop it
[Music]
turns out ranges on shotguns not that
good
ooh buddy
there's so little health too
but you know i did accidentally pull out
a grenade um i maintained that i
deserved this
frankly i deserve much worse than i just
got
power weapons huh what i just got a
ricochet weapon
is that gonna be this
okay how does it work
i've not used one yet
maybe it doesn't give me a path i think
that i have used one of these but like i
just don't recall
how
just no cops huh ah how do you keep
coming what is that like five of you
i don't even i don't want any of this
you know
i just don't feel like this is necessary
what okay what happens if i shoot it
there
oh oh i see
that's neat i just went up there that's
super cool i wonder if i can use that
tactically i'm probably gonna die here
don't judge me
it goes too high so i feel like that
would work if somebody was on like the
second
story um really just tearing through
this good thing i've been looting so
much
[Applause]
do we get in cover man
they do take a lot of hits i'll tell you
that
like that how many bullets is it'll be
reinforced though on
wouldn't they they'd all have like
reinforced skeletons and stuff
i feel like that makes sense okay can we
get this head shot i don't know that we
can i don't know that we can
no i'm sorry yeah i'm sorry about this
massacre that's just happened right in
front of you wait do you want to leave
oh she might have and i just screwed it
up that's my bad she was screaming
though
that's my bad i'm you know i'm just
started playing the grenades where i was
accidental
and now i'm murdering all your loved
ones and i'm really sorry about it
stop we don't have to do this if you
don't want to
but it keeps seeming to me like you do
[ __ ] i don't know what i expected
ah the cops is here oh the cops okay we
gotta we gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
we gotta we gotta go we gotta go
hey you [ __ ] off can you get the [ __ ]
out of my way
oh heck
at least i've had the experience you
know we've gotta we gotta figure it out
somehow
i mean i didn't mean to go on a massacre
i'm very sorry everyone
i pulled out that grenade by accident
and i'm really sorry about it
i you know i don't
i don't want any of this call my car
wow
okay
we did it
gotta remember that the cops are nowhere
near as bad as they are in
eta all right well um you know that
didn't go
according to plan
but we're okay now
how do i change the camera angle
not sure
uh of course it's close well i can just
wait
we can skip time i'm not going to loot
the civilians i murdered no because i
didn't want to be there when the cops
showed up
so i just left um
i didn't mean to kill them
i mean i meant to kill all the ones that
i shot but i didn't mean to initiate
combat
sometimes you just accidentally throw a
grenade
we've all been there we've all been
there okay you can't tell me you haven't
been there
um let me read some more donations for
the record for anyone who's just joining
me these are donations for charity
no donations for me um i don't even take
money on twitch
uh john braswell donated 20 john olsen
donated 20
and said super excited to hear details
about what you're working on with sony
santa monica
yep roaming g he donated ten dollars
martin beaton donated fifty dollars
saints recruit donated fifty dollars
a lot of good donations thank you guys
so much uh be careful good donation
amount he donated
20.77 said hi alana greetings from new
york i'm a big fan of work and
appreciate your boundless capacity to
entertain educate us on the video game
industry and caring for others by your
charity streams
thank you i don't know about entertain
but i do try to be informative and kind
uh congratulations on a successful year
on youtube and with your new role at
sony said i wanna go thank you
i appreciate it um if you guys would
like to donate let me
throw the link in here
you can do that right here and
uh yeah raising money to
help people who are in need okay
i only need to do one hour boom
uh yes aha hello
how's it going honeybun i like her hey
there doll face
bright pink boop covers do you want a
preem
those are cool
sure and i go also her legs
house rules first are those pants
effectively severe penalties for any
unauthorized
i like the marks a lot no drugs no
groping
okay someone catch your eye you do not
grab them
you find them in the catalog ask for a
bd and get yourself a box
i really look that green to you like i
don't know
doors open thank you have fun doll bye
welcome to lizzie's do strip clubs open
at 6 p.m i don't know what time they
open
me or that
that's a pretty sweet face kiss my dead
spunk
i was just trying to say hi and then
hey what my
what a sweet little face you have thank
you what the [ __ ] man
let me show you trying to raise money
for charity and
i she said kiss my tits punk
hey thank you evan it's just very
unexpected
jeez uh
thank you to listed for the 20 dollars
in chet that's amazing for the hundred
dollars
thank you guys um i don't know if we
will be able to raise
five thousand dollars by the time i need
to go to sleep
but it would be pretty cool you know
it'd be pretty cool is all i'm saying
uh okay she looks like your ex congrats
curtis
would you guys just hang out in the
lobby of a
of a strip club is that that what you're
about
you just smoke hanging out yes what's up
no it's fine no that's
hey i get it um
everyone has their digs
no surprise there
i still think the fact that this game
doesn't have any loading screens is
insane i do also just want to
acknowledge that i'm playing this on
good hardware you know this is on a 3080
and
i am i feel like my experience is solid
and maybe my expectations weren't as
high as other people's i don't know
i don't know oh they're brain dancing
i hope that that can't trigger a seizure
for anyone i should have put a seizure
warning on my stream i don't want anyone
to have a seizure but i hope looking at
those flashing lights doesn't
or any of this doesn't do that it
shouldn't now i don't know though is the
truth i just don't know what
induces seizures uh but i obviously have
heard about that and
sounds like cdpr are trying to address
that
cool bra
i hate your voice though you sound like
holly quinn hi
a pudding ain't nothing for free
more cool music okay hey bro what up
yo what up
thank you zombie you're right if
everyone donated two dollars
you hit the goal you don't have to don't
know what you don't have to do it just a
single dollar
good stuff good stuff
oh thank you i appreciate the the props
for my
uh lizzie died right for my harley quinn
the name lizzy's that the owner
not for a long while no and it's none
too sweet of story
oh now i'm just flat interested real
lizzy ran
she died at this place back in the day
wait this isn't a distributor
those were paid right insured and had
decency
is it a separate thing good spot all in
all is somebody just doing 800
am i misreading that
thank you devon they said thank you for
bringing all those viewers the
opportunity to support our fellow hungry
americans and give back to those
who could use a little help from our
friends also congrats on a successful
career and all
the many opportunities ahead thank you
that's very kind double kind thank
you sean mcgraw also donated a five
dollars thank you sean
um that's awesome thank you guys i don't
is this a a dance club or um maybe it's
it's her she's here
you know i just didn't
expect to see you so soon
what do i say
perfect look at the way she sips a drink
am i the simp
i think i might be um but i just want to
make sure i make a good first impression
oh hey
don't look at me
do you know how cool you have to be to
lean on a ball backwards like that
that's very cool oh
oh okay
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry uh hey mateo
we're just having a chill chat over here
just
casually
stories of the golden days inevitable
demise and the inevitable drink over
sweet memories
all will make some dog tales let's have
a look
shall we
all negatives do any of these have
positives i wonder
oh it's water that checks out
hydration status increases maximum by 10
region by 50
per second it's interesting it's
interesting
whoa we had two thousand dollars when
did that happen
when did that happen what oh my gosh
it's what happened out of nowhere uh
super nintendo carrie was
250 thank you so much tia hancia i hope
i pronounced that correctly is three
dollars
ray png also donated a hundred dollars
thank you nebulous noir twenty dollars
martin beaton uh donated fifty dollars
said from a scotsman in la
to some american kids via an aussie in
l.a
here's another video to help us get over
the line tonight keep up the good work
cobber
thank you anonymously ten dollars and
then murder she got very nice donated
ten dollars thank you guys so much
that's crazy oh thank you i appreciate
it you're amazing
well okay back to the video game
of course we are donating to feed hungry
americans
i'm gonna just buy some spunky monkey
that's monkey monkey
looking for evelyn parker know if she's
here
who's asking
does it look like i'm looking at her
where did she go
[Music]
she's right there so i don't really feel
like i need to ask you about this
pleasure
did she walk away as soon as i looked at
her i deserve that probably
it's all right
hello evelyn
i'm you you seem very large
evelyn parker this game's gonna look so
good ultra wide just keep
i knew it was you as soon as you walked
in i knew
it was you soon as you walked in
shame on me that i
v uh when are you coming to not say
hello sooner
i wanted to get a good look
[Music]
trouble
[Music]
my favorite taylor swift songs i was
just thinking this morning literally
this morning while i was trying to fall
asleep at [ __ ] 7 a.m
um about how i don't know why i do not
like taylor swift as much as most people
like i wonder how that's happened i
don't know
okay hello
nice
this i guess stream is also getting
demonetized on youtube nothing monetized
well actually no my other stream did get
demonetized and age gated both of them
but dex had a load to say about you
called you professional
thank you and trustworthy
i hope he wasn't overselling
i don't really want to say either of
those i know that i could but i don't
want to
i'm waiting sister texted me
wait what is she getting mad at me for
she just said okay uh
don't know him well haven't worn
together long just cut to chase let's
see this one no idea if dex exaggerates
um sorry i feel like you just called me
out i was working until 7 00.
not hanging out i was working
they saw me there are two kinds of
fixers
oh stable crews on long contracts and
short leashes
loyalty and predictability they value
above all else
then there's the other kind dex's
kind i genuinely don't know what happens
with dex i really should get through
this game so it doesn't get spoiled for
me huh
yeah loyalty and predictability they
value above all else
v um i wish he wouldn't bug me so soon
the other kind come on can't leave that
hanging
head hunters they lay their trust
elsewhere
not in people but in a thing their
intuition
they bet on people um comic
chasm said why does everybody smoke in
this game mistake they ever made
i believe there is a reason for that um
i've said this repeatedly i've avoided
the law
surrounding this game um always give a
shout out to
madqueen on youtube as a channel that uh
does a lot of lore deep dives i've
intentionally avoided it until i finish
the game and then i will do my deep
dives
but i feel like i've picked up a crumb
of there being a reason why smoking is
so popular
key tech in the program actually i don't
know what it is
making this highest one listen i would
like the record to state that i think
uh smoking is gross and you should not
do it because it's really bad for you
stands for technology
but i also would never like actually get
mad at someone for doing it
it's fine the chip is tucked away
smoking isn't cool stop saying that
hotel
you ever been never had the opportunity
you know
just never rolled through that
neighborhood damn shame
the fresh they serve is sinfully good
chef must have made a deal with the
devil so where's this chip hiding
exactly in a suite on the top floor
the room's occupied by yori nobu
honestly we are getting close to the
first braindance
he's in town don't you read the scream
sheets
the media couldn't get enough of yori
coming to night city
it was all over the headlines anyway
he's heir apparent to the arasaka empire
saburo arasaka's only surviving sun
what so arasaka juniors planning to grab
the reigns while in night city
only a handful of people in night city
know what the arasaka's real plans are
telling me you're one of them
she's not narasaka we know that
okay um
v so we're not jumping the corp we're
jumping you are nobu arasaka i actually
don't think that's true i think she's
wrong
yori nobu is a puppet he lost all his
cards years ago when he failed to do
daddy's bidding
saburo's had yuri's balls in a vice for
years
he might just turn the screw and crush
them outright if he learns his son's up
to no good again
very disappointed with the graphics are
you kidding this game is beautiful i
know i have to remember
you're playing it on different settings
top dog like you are no boo but me i
think it's beautiful
hotel's probably a goddess i don't have
an answer to that i don't know
yori nobu keeps exactly no hustle around
not one guard got rid of them a long
time ago
huh why is that surely you know what
they say about arasaka intel
i do not sneeze in night city and a
blossom drops from a cherry tree in
tokyo
yorinobu was convinced his arasaka
security detail reported directly to his
father
okay look if you've got any spare aces
up your sleeve
now's the time to show them now this
should make your tits perk up iorinobu
recently swiped the chip before
laboratory he's made a deal with
netwatch
aims to sell it to them have you
spotted my ace yet or do i need to spell
things out
um
[Music]
i don't remember what i did i actually
feel like this has changed since since
when i played it
um no watch something just neutral that
watch is mixed up in this
netwatch provides net security for all
corporations
and collects eddie's in the millions for
the millions you said
in this day and age everyone's in the
game and no one can afford to be a saint
to win one has to go all in
um so what's your nobu do to walk away
with
not important you focus on the biochip
okay
what could cyberspace's watchers and
protectors offer him i believe the
biochemist
has johnny silva that doesn't matter in
the least
because you'll make sure the transaction
never happens and i
get the chip fine so no arasaka security
on the device because your nobu
whisked it away in secret now where's he
hiding it
likely in a specialized container one
that
mimics an organic neural environment on
the outside it looks like an
ordinary briefcase and the case is
i think we find the briefcase in the
brainerd provided we're done gossiping
about the outer stock
okay okay what's next now comes the best
part
follow me got something for you should
help you plan
brain dance from come back so i think i
probably need to turn
music off
for this
sadly
which is a bummer what's a brain dance
supposed to help need facts not thrills
i can still hear music
maybe the base is counted as a sound
effect jacking off too in those boxes
no it can be a very useful tool of
course
good for analyzing details human
perception
even boosted doesn't grasp exactly what
you need
so what's on the tape yorinobu suite
the glorious interior you'll need to
locate the relic yourself
hope i grabbed enough detail to make
that possible
i think this game's so cool
hey
um oh wait
uh i'm not a fan
i don't like this i would like to stop
this from happening
is he helping her maybe he is
okay yeah he is she's she's vomiting and
he's helping her i apologize for judging
you sir i thought that you were
attacking the woman who's clearly very
drunk
you may continue okay never mind sorry
it's my bad apologies
yeah continue i'm sorry i didn't mean to
i'll do whatever i can to fix it
i love gods
where are you kiss my dead spunk
why are they so rude why are they so
rude my what a sweet little face you
have hey that's the same thing the other
lady said okay
it's originality oh
bathroom very nice
i'm off the clock hon yeah that's fair
i'm just trying to make friends so
i do really like the moxes i like that
vibe i like what they're about i want to
be friends with them
but none of them like me apparently okay
not that i needed that right now excuse
me excuse me thank you
take all of the things what's up nina
see you recorded this
video bdrack implant why you object
it is pretty [ __ ] up supposed to be
your no boost pad on the tape
means you were inside you uh know each
other
how else could i get all this intel i
know him pretty well actually we have a
[ __ ] an arrangement
strictly business suits us both i think
let's see this
i guess that could still be [ __ ]
technically
judy will help technically he's a mox
too can you see
your character at all you can um
if i go to the character screen
no inventory hey that's me
i hate what i'm wearing but you know
we'll get there
that's all we got for now i like the
shoes in the pants actually it's the top
that i'm not a fan of
um and the uh
oh my god judy's gonna be in here you're
right oh god um
the mirrors are all matte but they
basically have like a button that stops
them from being matte
uh so you can see your reflections
important judy's always been there for
me
always helped out yeah really i trust
her that's cool but she's a mox
not the latest member of your crew i
like moxes try not to forget
i feel good about that be a good girl
tread lightly
and keep that tongue on don't worry
about me around judy famous
believe it or not i'm no stranger to
tact in biz or life
i am around judy though you're a lot
braver than me
um we can't agree on that
oh okay
is somebody in here what are you doing
i'm looting it's an rpg
um you're supposed to look at the
environments and pick up the stuff
and then sell half of it later for money
uh it's ridiculous that you don't know
this
i can't believe she had to ask see this
nope
so i guess not all the mirrors go
unmatte but um i know the one your
apartment does at the very least uh
uh okay anything anything else whoa why
is that so aggressive
what does this sound hmm
hey you come here often
hey there you are this is v
she's here for that bd role and v
this is judy best brain dance editor i
know
enough already gonna make me barf
hey judy
compiled your bdf what do you think
will it do i hope she likes me i'm sorry
that my shirt's ugly
mm-hmm v needs to get i'd love to look
cool
it's most important so let's calibrate
it
believe me i've dealt with worse i
should see the jig jig street porn we
got to continue
i'd love to hang out watch that with you
sometimes so
we dropped the inside better look let
her
run right it's cool that's fine
raw brain dance ever taken a dip before
look i'm no bd virgin why did you say
that v for [ __ ] sake
uncharted 2. this is not what i was
going for relax i'll explain everything
less complicated than it sounds sit down
settle in and we'll get you going i feel
like i already [ __ ] it up
i [ __ ] it up it's already done and now
she's never gonna date me
and i don't want to play the game
anymore if my chances are ruined because
v said something that i didn't want me
to say
so every let's say
uh epilepsy warning right now is a good
note anyone who's worried about epilepsy
there will be flashing lights right now
and i think all throughout this segment
worth noting stop looking please that'll
create your sensory profile first
okay okay hit me i love you by the way
just promise me it won't be really cute
it won't
huh you can help me if you want what no
sit still
look at me going to run the analysis
soft
should feel a slight tingling
i'd love to look at her okay now let's
set the optics and others
get out of the way look smack into these
two screens
pretend it's an eye exam
get a lot of requests like this all the
time
but it's usually stuff the girls scroll
at the club i take that and
do some routine porn tuning porn tuning
pick up the orgasms
more like cut out all the other [ __ ]
[ __ ] business as usual for these guys
their minds wander to grocery lists
spouses birthdays
late bills whatever sometimes they do be
like that
you can re-figure things mold the
emotions into something unique
cool you want to like create unique
unforgettable experiences together
one more second no okay no that's pain
receptor limiters in that's cool
we could make our own brain dance okay
all set
okay i love you i need to test your
profile first tossing in a sample baby
you can use it to get to know the editor
now let me see
where could we can't you just use my
recording
why are we wasting time so we don't risk
our necks
i feel like this whole segment should
probably have music but doesn't because
i had to turn it off
also it's been a while since someone
donated i'm just saying you guys
okay i know we're all here for judy
objectively
i get that but we're also here to raise
money
for food banks in the us so people can
eat
you know what i'm saying and i did think
we got a couple let me read them out
before we do the brain dance
um christopher said
keep up the good work chica 2077 i love
that donation amount
mike donated 25 robotech said more
creepy atlanta please 20
malibu lizard said your lack of game
around judy made me feel bad for you
take my money 10
she's staring at me i mean
okay look i don't know what you're
talking about
but i feel like
if we just sort of
you know we just kind of
keep on sort of and then
hey you look like you're working maybe i
can do the other side then i can see it
there's a webcam let me sort of
look at us hanging out
look i just got my arm i'm a bit big
though hang on
maybe maybe there let me just
put down a bit maybe hey
so like what do you want to who's your
favorite pokemon
is it you like garedus because
that's cool
oh we're so like look at us
hanging out just looking at the same
thing
you know just sort of yeah
no i know it's crazy
anyway what did you what did you choose
what'd you choose corner store hold up
in hayward
don't even know where i got it
yeah no totally um
yeah no i'm that's cool so let me
oh i hope you're entertained because i'm
certainly entertained
uh okay so i don't i don't i don't want
to hear it
uh thank you
hang on uh judy and i have some
donations to read
thank you paul for the 20 you said good
luck at the awards today
um thank you i am very conflicted about
as you keep saying really not wanting to
win but also
really appreciating all of the support
it's been so nice
so thank you uh i do really appreciate
it um klutz a lot
donated 10 dollars said so proud to see
a fellow aussie smashing it in the field
they love congrats on the new dream job
too thank you it really is a dream job
um dust flight said it's not very much
but small amount helps this is
absolutely true five dollars counts
and the nebulous noise followed that up
with a two dollar donation instead
everyone please
donate two dollars judy do you want to
read the last one
no um it's from anonymous who donated
five dollars you didn't want to
you know care about feeding america or
she's she's just a bit unwell lately so
are you
what are you like what kind of charities
do you like
who who do you try to raise money for in
your spare time
judy is it you know um
i am only going to leave this screen
if we hit 2 300.
otherwise you're staying here
at least i entertain myself really got
me through this year you know what i'm
saying
trans justine donated two dollars saying
oh my gosh thank you for this
here's hoping you and judy get married
um i think i know you from twitter thank
you
uh brent blue allen donated 20 and said
thank you to the streamers with faster
computers that'll let me play this game
vicariously i'm sorry brent
this probably isn't what you wanted
so chill quill
said judy loves feeding families judy
did you have any
anything you want to say about that or
you're just gonna
she she whispered it was really quick so
you couldn't see her mouth me but she
said thank you for
acknowledging her love for feeding
families
uh scooterman gaming said looking for
the creepy
awkward alana edit on youtube i probably
could do a compilation of every time
that i hit on judy
she's beautiful i don't you didn't hear
that did you
you didn't i didn't say anything it's
too soon for compliments
uh thank you for five dollars ray png
donated another 2077.
um thank you ray png for the multiple
donations he said feed them kids
but i'm not leaving until we hit 2 300.
i don't know judy do you think i'm
pretty
sorry i misread the body language there
so
that's fine someone in the chat said
lame i'm out
[Laughter]
oh god ah
amazing uh
justin h said is this the entry to the
simp duty get together yes five dollar
donation fee
gets you into the club you're right
mighty bush she is the strong silent
type she's perfect
so i can't i'm not gonna
it's i'm it's forced hopper hand you
know how they have photos where the
dudes are like overhandling
i physically can't it's forced
what hell is this
uh thank you jcb um i'm not moving
until we get to 2 300. that's 60 dollars
be clear i don't want to move you'd be
making me do something i don't want to
do
thank you tate for donating two dollars
my graphics so good to be fam my
graphics are really good but it looks
terrible right now because it zooms so
far in
certainly not how the game was intended
to be streamed so
you know how it is you know how it is
oh good night bosco jones
he said i would like to donate but i
like the bit oh we did it
we did it okay okay thank you for the
donations
i hate that you took me away from my
wife but thank you ray
i hope my mouth gets it through this
monologue it does perfectly all right
okay it's time to zoom out i get it you
guys hate my love for judy that's fine
it's whatever it's not a big deal let me
just put the video game back together
actually don't know if there's a smarter
way to
i could just go reset transform right if
i get transform
reset transform boom there you go that's
the easiest way to do it ah
no it stay that video game but the dude
proof this
okay we did it
uh against user warning
so you know also you know please
continue to donate that would be tight
okay let's go
let me give you the tailored version
first let you get your bearings
and we'll jump into editing mode be
diving in three
two one
hmm plan simple
do nothing odd don't get creative you go
in snatch the cash
get out and we sell the bd to those
psycho freaks from our studio
got it got it and remember everything
uh 555 zimmerman said why is this stream
quality bad
it's not it's just youtube compression
um
because the bit rate's lower than i'm on
you want it to be when i stream on two
platforms it looks better on twitch
funnel enough
uh but i don't really care where you
watch
that's up to you everybody autograph i
want to see you kissing the flooring
money now where i will [ __ ] drop you
i swear to god
whoa yeah now
before i blow your [ __ ] head off who
did that rubik's cube though that's sick
well that's big money oh so it's only a
four-way rubik's cube
slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers
nothing happened
she's really close to you guys
just breathe slowly sorry yeah calmly
you're okay
it's all right
okay um i want to say nice something
nice not too much
too much how you do your eyeliner so
well i feel
the guys paint how do those wings get so
good
guys i'm sweating something else
i probably took a booster just before
you'll be fine
got everything set up let's switch over
to editing mode
i respect you as professional and i'm
really sorry that i keep taking that
away from me
i want you to know you seem very good at
your job
i'm sorry i'll sever the link to the bd
roller's sensory array
you'll be able to look around freely all
the scenes yours
okay full cam control and analysis mode
so move around
zoom in and out whatever else you come
up with
so analysis mode you control playback
can even pause when you feel the need
then you use the editor console to
unpause try it
don't get creative you go in snatch the
cash
get out and we sell the pd to those
psycho breaks from the studio
got it got it dream as hell right pretty
sick pretty sick thank you thank you
speed things up or rewind
whatever you like we had 2500 what what
happened back to the top what happened
here oh
i have donations to read i'm sorry judy
uh i adore you aggressively
but i have things to read uh where are
we up to
marcus to ten dollars
oh abandoned said did you ask judy for
permission before you got off in a
successful space like that
i didn't no wait i did when you're
referring to me sitting next door i did
she seemed okay with it you're right
though i should have asked
consent is cool uh 20 eric mick
20 said i love all that you do for
charity i hope i can find myself in a
place where i can do
as much someday i don't know that i'm in
a place where i should be doing it if
i'm honest
as much as i do um
no that's not true everyone could always
do more for other people i take it back
even if it ties me out sometimes uh boob
donated two hundred dollars black swan
dre donated 20. and said hope you're
having a good time playing the game
congrats on the new job thank you and
thank you i really am enjoying the game
even though again it feels like a really
weird game to stream because i'm playing
it so slow
nebulous noir donated two dollars and
said at 3k back to judy podcast
oh incredible uh thank you for 2500. we
are halfway to the goal i don't know
that we're gonna hit it today because i
am gonna have to stop
it's 12. i should stop soon um
i would love to but
if we can't then we can't and that's
okay okay
uh lt to rewind a brain dance along you
hold the foster
rewinds
that's gonna be auntie do nothing odd
don't get crazy
okay you can also reset the recording
that'll take you right back to the
beginning
try it now for some fun this here's why
you came in
to see you yes in analysis mode you get
to
view
you want me to stay in analysis mode for
this i have already done this for the
record but i feel like the braindance uh
cdpr were telling me step by step
exactly what to do so i never really
paid attention to it as far as the
tutorial goes
it's i think it's still an analysis mode
they just want me to
watch the gun being passed
um okay there we go
bold sections on the track indicate this
is not that different to the way the
outcome series does it
um which it's just the tracks that don't
get me uh the clue will be highlighted
for the duration of the sequence if the
editor is set to the correct
layer may overlap okay
excellent thank you move you impressed
now heads up in analysis you can ferret
out background noise and conversations
if the roller got close enough
this tech records everything every
little detail
i don't want any of this this is messed
up
to see the sources of the recorded
sensory signals switch to the audio
layer in the editor
go ahead and try that now okay good
now you should see several sound
signatures in the store
choose one and hone in on it in the
store you want me to go inside
that's going to be maybe the gunshot
pack of six cases
gotcha we have a deal today on two
flavors
everybody so any thoughts i just think
you're really pretty oh
seriously you mean about the princess
it's happening right next to me that's
fine
yeah it's how bd recording implants work
they pick up
everything all the elements in the
background then an editor tweaks them
makes them pop make some keep playing
with the sound explore it a bit
we'll move on when you get bored okay
cool
sometimes you can analyze extra layers
in the raw stuff the rollers cyberware
picked up
like what ed's got kiroshi optics that
grab
infrared meaning you should be able to
just oh boy yeah i want this
hella nice hey thank you alex wait until
the guy punches out the gunk at the
counter
cyberpunk 2077 is the next skyrim i mean
it's not that far off
not that far off
so i still can't go to the middle layer
where the customer gets hit
you don't hit them you do hit them
scanning works on peeps too walk up to
the wounded chick
try scanning her i just scanned her next
thing
scroll forward to the part where our
artist gets a nut injection
oh that's right
if you are our artist that's about here
right
right see that
they shot him and he never saw him
but you will here it comes my favorite
part of the game
see the blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam
must have caught our shooter you'll see
in a sec
cam feeds to the screen behind the clerk
roll back to where the screen's in the
kids field of vision
then scan it
oh wait oh because they have to be
perceiving it
yeah okay
hmm his own chumba shot him
probably plan two all along must have
got a nice slice of cred on the black
market for a bd like this
bd freaks are ready to pay a prem for a
real flat line
anyway if you've seen enough you can
exit we had three thousand dollars
oh my gosh yeah let me before i go back
to judy and get all flustered again
oh my gosh oh my gosh
uh again if my stream looks bad on
youtube it's just youtube's compression
it does that sometimes um when i stream
on both platforms
um because youtube can take a higher bit
rate than twitch so youtube doesn't
work well on the lower bitrate that i do
for twitch so if you do want to again
i'm not gonna like try and tell people
not to watch on youtube but um
twitch.tv slash carolina's it should
look clearer
that said this is supposed to look
pretty pixelated obviously
uh
let me check the donations thank you for
3 000 everybody
that's amazing
uh we're up to
go skill donate fifty dollars ray p g oh
my gosh
four hundred dollars and said pay that
shiz forward
that's amazing thank you so much ray
that's crazy and then who likes
spaghetti uh donated
five dollars and we're now at three
thousand and fifty
and then mr gilbert just donated a
hundred dollars folks gotta eat thanks
for all you do by the way um i was gonna
be like yeah go eat but that's not what
you're saying it's because you did
anybody did the charity that we
everything ready for
nebulous noah donated ten dollars
instead still have hope for 5k
i got i really got to sleep like any
minute now
we've almost been streaming for two
hours i would love to
but i don't think we will make it
because i need to be up at six
tomorrow so that i can finish work early
to watch game awards
sadly uh thank you ryan
yeah sleep is important
okay back to my girl judy
yeah it's impressive right it's too bad
most of the bds we do here are only good
for flogging the log
that's true yeah totally i agree with
everything you've ever said
i don't know i ugh let's
take a break still feel like that kid
would
yeah i bet that's pretty messed up it's
pretty messed up
v there's no time get it together please
okay okay
go ahead i just need t-buck to link in
whoa whoa whoa whoo runner for my crew
security specialist
she'll tell me what to look for while we
analyze no problem
i hope actually oh no oh no i created a
problem
what we agreed is
judy t-bug's a professional discreet to
a fault
you can trust her why cause you say so
oh no
uh please i'll do whatever you want i'm
sorry
uh whatever you want i'd never expose
you to any danger
you know that
all right i'm gonna do the second brain
dance
um hey v what's happening
i got some useful footage from so i can
go to sleep it's a brain dance
con pecky oh thought as much
someone there with you
an important bug please focus need your
help
what do you distribute for a second all
right see if i can walk you through it
jack uh jason you've got to give me you
don't
choose a personality
should be getting my requests now
got it you ready a millisecond
okay connection confirmed now some quick
tip ice
and we're clear ready to dance
fire up judy
wait did i call judy unimportant
i did technically didn't i all right
eyes open
gotta find out where your know who's
keeping the relic devastated
wouldn't be the first time a man said
that to me i felt her fear
sure got an underground no when i
started snorting it's so weird
no they'll have my head for this
then you shall perish for a good cause
but
make yourself comfortable just thought
we'd watch the whole thing first listen
in on that conversation v
could be something or not or not
that's going to be audio layer
no no no no this one uh is it this maybe
no it would be it would be from him
maybe here i need a minute to finish
the program is still in the trial phase
we cannot take it to market as is
we shall see soon enough please speak
with your father
he's taken a particular interest in this
project he can certainly explain the
risks my fathers are tired
visual this old grey beard who thinks
nothing will
change and he'll live forever in his
tiny
frozen bubble not
of a world that no longer exists
of a world that may never have existed
we have not seen eye to eye it wants me
to still listen to something i'm just
assuming it's the phone or did you want
me to listen to the tv
we want now read the documentation
carefully
the relic requires specific storage
conditions still there
heard that relic docs got to be around
here somewhere
look for them gotcha i have
not run into myself yet george no
um that would be back to this layer
what am i looking for a relic doc
scan his daughter pad that's in here
isn't it
do i need to walk out here
or can i
that's not a daughter pattern sorry to
make you win
i think that it's in it's by the bed
if i remember correctly where wait where
are we going
oh this is a security system it didn't
want me to do this didn't it
also no maybe i do not know
there it is this one
there we go manual details a special
temp control container
relic needs to be kept real cool so
chips gotta stay in the freezer
yep could damage it otherwise okay
switch on thermal layer detection in the
editor
should be easier to spot where you are
no boos keeping the chip
get back over here oh we can scan this
or not
it is definitely further back uh
hey culver i think it says in the
youtube
title doesn't it i'm playing on pc
it is this thing that i'm trying to scan
well we can scan this while we're at it
hello mate
oh donaghy's looks like
fancy i guess i don't know really think
you'll find the chip in there
no no way tim's too low could fluctuate
nice try though thank you wait till she
walks over there
go for it love okay this one maybe then
i don't remember exactly just a fancy
ass fridge
tim doesn't match the guidelines won't
find a thing here
i really thought it was like in a wall
or something it's it's a safe um
where else do you walk that has
temperature
that's it grab the heat sig matches the
spec in the docks
that's it your nobody's got the case
here
guaranteed it's a pretty sweet apartment
it's shame that it looks so hideous
but what if i want to scan the
apartment's security systems
when does she do that after all this i
think
nope so when she walks in we're going to
change the layer
beautiful yeah good stuff
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh what is a brain dance uh brain dance
is basically like a um
uh something somebody has recorded that
you can watch back that's kind of like a
last time um
okay this is what i wanted to see is
this editing mode
what uh thermal visual it would be
visual wouldn't it
can i i think i can do it for me i'm
just assuming i can do it from here
but maybe i'm wrong
very nice i forgot what i was saying
for the perfect scene i think maybe i
need to pause when i see something that
looks
you'll like this about right
no i don't know how to do it
um unless it's right here
nope i'm gonna guess this middle one
this bit right here also
what are you trying to make me look at
here then
i'm not sure not sure uh whatever
it don't matter
get everything you need yeah i did yeah
that'll do thanks for asking thanks judy
we got it thank you later bug
thank you
i really want a data put it on
portable device for handling vds i
already uploaded your calibration
settings
you're perfect look how efficient you
are what we got here
we should do the trick i i bet it's
super efficient
clever thank you speaking of harm's way
know what i see roast me judy walking
talking okay is this good
we needed that recording i don't know bd
practically does our job for us
the bd will be the death of us seriously
if arasaka finds out you have it you're
dead
i'm dead judy relax
nobody will ever know evelyn please
no shortcuts oh evelyn's here go that
route
oh that's right so be careful
of course i will be besides
we'll talk in a bit
okay i think i need to leave it there so
i can sleep
i'm very tired v
one sec let me just do this first thanks
judy
really and don't worry
i know what i'm doing
nothing that's
seems inviting
all right fine um okay you guys i gotta
stop so i can sleep thank you everyone
so much
for the 3160
you can still donate if you like the
link is in the description or if you do
the donate
command on twitch whatever i don't know
how any of this works
uh i did not hit five grand it's okay
we raised three thousand dollars to feed
people just now
that's amazing um thank you all thank
you everyone who donated
and yeah i will be streaming the game
awards tomorrow from
4 p.m pacific time i'm not going to
stream the pre-show because
again i have work um but i will be doing
it
with my buddy ethan over discord and
obviously
i'm gonna drink some white clothes and
and have a good time
and watch the show so it should be fun
um
it's four hours which just seems like
so long um but hopefully we get some
cool
reveals that make it worth it
so yeah it should be awesome thank you
everyone and if you want to
watch tomorrow i will be again on
youtube and twitch uh probably primarily
on youtube for that one but um
yeah we'll make it work either way and
let me just leave the link in here
in case anyone would like to donate
there you go
you can do that uh
i will see you guys next time